le Premier ministre d'Haïti Ariel Henry
lance un appel à l'aide pour éviter la
catastrophe humanitaire
[Musique]
toute bagage montée technique
il demande entre autres à ses
partenaires internationaux le
déploiement immédiat d'une force armée
spécialisée en Haïti
à l'heure actuelle les gains criminels
contrôleraient 90% de la capitale
Port-au-Prince et ces banlieues dont les
principaux points de ravitaillement en
essence les engrais payer les prix des
dents réels les plus essentiels comme
l'eau et les médicaments
11 cas de choléra ont maintenant été
confirmés dont 7 décès
c'est une question de temps avant que la
maladie se propage de façon
exponentielle selon les Nations Unies
après l'assassinat du président jovenel
Moïse l'enquête piétine et la situation
économique politique et sociale du pays
s'aggravent
certains juges que le premier ministre
actuel est dépassé par les événements
moi je pense que la demande du Premier
ministre c'est un acte de
faiblesse c'est un acte de son échec
mais ça va rester comme ça
malheureusement c'est parce que on n'a
pas de la commande de pouvoir reste
quelque chose ça fait longtemps ça
continue encore je crois que Monsieur
Henri est en train de penser que seul un
intervention étrangère peut lui
permettre soit de rester provisoirement
au pouvoir soit de pouvoir lui-même ne
pas être victime de cette situation dans
laquelle il a entraîné le pays depuis un
an
reste à voir si des partenaires majeurs
comme les États-Unis et le Canada et la
France répondront présents avec une
opération militaire sur le terrain alors
que la guerre en Ukraine retient
beaucoup la tension ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal